ready yeah hey guys this is the making
up for clock blockers in this video
we're gonna show you guys how we came up
with the idea how we planned it out and
how we shot it and did all the crazy
effects pretty much everything so start
things off how did we come up with the
idea for clock blockers oh yeah we want
to make a gun fight but we didn't want
to be just a boring gunfights
so he decided to come up with a twist
the twist was we had clones that was
made out of fine time clones fabricated
from the very essence of time itself but
it was a time-travel gunfight where
people could travel back in time and
like and correct the mistakes that they
made in the action scene so everyone
would have a chance to do it right and
do it wait for that and so then we were
driving to do our Western shoot in the
desert and Nicko sunlight proclaimed in
the middle of driving we should called
Walker his mission we should call it
clock blockers so for the clone shots
there were two basic ways that we did
them one was pretty much we would shoot
our master plate to add the other guys
what we did is we shot them handheld
with a camera as still as possible and
then we would stabilize that footage
later you can use a tripod by the way
you can use a tripod instead it's much
easier but regardless you take your
footage shot on a tripod or your
stabilized footage and just put that
onto your motion track shot that was the
most common effect and then we had a
couple shots they're a little bit
crazier where we actually had like a
significantly moving camera as well as
people that are moving and for that we
actually would film each person handheld
keeping them in frame we did it Buju
nodal plan track for each camera took
those cameras in the 3dsmax projected
the camera map onto the inside of the
sphere for each camera put the master
camera and did a rendering of the
projection maps from the other cameras
with the master camera proud that nat
effects messes it out and then we had a
final shot Wow and as you can see there
there's a whole tutorial that needs to
be included with that first to make any
sense at all Sam hey how do we do that
tire shot that was pretty cool helping
gets to people
how did we do it well what we did for
the tire shot is we basically filmed me
running into the shot so then we painted
out Jake and Messer shot and got another
clip of Sam in a blue shirt
pretending to push the tire it wasn't
actually any tire there and stuck them
into that shot so it looks like blue
shirt Sam actually pushes the tire the
kind of a complicated shot and
fortunately it's kind of one of the most
messy ones we did but this cool and you
guys liked it so it off right yep
because of the complexities of shooting
scene with ten people in it
not to mention ten people who have
actions constantly repeated and changed
and interacted and interfered with over
time we had to build a small timeline
showing all the characters what they do
when they do it basically I had to line
up all the people and make sure that all
their actions were not only consistent
but lined up with each other in time so
that we didn't have any paradoxes so to
speak now a lot of people also ask did
you guys have your clones shoot the
video no actually they didn't shoot the
video it was Arthur to--and and Nicola
Ron both those guys helped to shoot the
Minecraft we put up this February and we
both stuck another video with us again
annotation so I hope you guys learned
everything you wanted to learn and if
you didn't hit us up on Twitter or
Facebook because we answered all our
messages or at least trumpets thanks for
watching guys keep having fun on the
Internet yep keep surfing it Surf's Up
dude yeah you guys were wondering why
were really tired because we've been in
the desert for three days yeah I mean we
had to finish this video
you